welcome back so we're talking about
machine learning control using
data-driven optimizations to control
complex nonlinear dynamical systems so
that's this picture here we've talked
about how we can use genetic programming
which is essentially this recursive
function tree representation to
iteratively design better and better
control law trees to control some
unknown black box dynamical system and
now what I'm going to tell you about is
essentially how we have applied this
basic architecture of this genetic
programming control in particular to
control turbulent fluid dynamical
systems so this is work that was led by
Barrett Nowak and his collaborators in a
series of experiments across across
Europe and you can read about this in a
book by Toma Duryea myself and Barrett
but the basic idea is that you know the
kind of big picture goal is machine
learning control of turbulence and so
turbulent fluid dynamics are a high
dimensional nonlinear multi scale
problem okay so they're governed by
equations that we do know the navier--
stokes equations but to simulate or
represent the solutions we might need
millions or billions of degrees of
freedom and that is not amenable for
fast real-time control design especially
considering that these turbulent fluids
have very fast timescales motivating a
very fast control decision for low
latency high bandwidth control so lots
and lots of work has and is still going
into getting reduced order models of
turbulence for control that's a huge
field of research
I know Behrendt and myself have both
worked in these reduced order models for
fluids but what I'm going to tell you
about now is essentially instead of
trying to model the turbulence for
control instead we're going to use these
machine learning ideas this Genetic
Programming controlled directly to find
effective control laws to manipulate
turbulence now I love talking about this
because this is one of the grand
challenge problems of the modern era so
turbulent fluids are at the
nearly every trillion-dollar industry so
transportation right this is a huge
industry transportation is centered
around working fluids so reducing the
drag on a car or you know the the drag
behind a ship or an airplane or a train
defense
okay so making more agile aircraft and
and and boats and you know so
transportation and defense are huge
power systems getting energy from
systems engines and and turbines health
systems optimizing the flow inside of
people's bodies inside their hearts and
their veins and their arteries okay so
working fluids are at the center of
everything we live in a fluid and so if
you can get performance gains in
turbulence control you have the
potential to improve almost all of these
applications okay so you can increase
lift decrease drag change the mixing and
a flow those are all high level
objectives that can directly translate
into better performance in these systems
so even you know improving the mixing in
a combustion engine by a few percent
might translate to billions of dollars
of global savings annually I mean these
are these are huge problems and even a
little bit of improvement can translate
to big you know big performance gains
okay so again just a shameless plug we
wrote a book on this a springer book
that you can you can read about machine
learning control taming nonlinear
dynamics and turbulence that's what
Amadori a myself and Barrett Nowak where
we talk about applying these Genetic
Programming controls to some turbulence
control problems right now I'm just
gonna walk you through one example on a
canonical flow that's kind of like this
mixing layer here that bear no no Akron
in poitiers France a few years ago okay
so this is the basic setup of this
mixing layer experiment and this was I
think run by Vladimir Peres zenovich who
is working with parent at the time so
you have this fast flow on the top slow
flow on the bottom with the
their plate this big metal plate in the
wind tunnel and you get this this
roll-up and eventual turbulent breakdown
in the mixing layer and in this
experiment you can measure 24 hot wire
measurements at some location downstream
and the objective is to try to either
increase or decrease the mixing kind of
the rate of this turbulent breakdown at
some downstream location so this is kind
of a canonical example that people think
of you know for wings or streamline
surfaces like automobiles and things
like that so the mixing layer is a
canonical flow that people have studied
for a long time and if we can increase
or decrease the mixing in this problem
we might be able to manipulate more
engineering relevant problems and so to
do this there's actually this splitter
plate here this this the splitter plate
has 96 pressure ports on the surface
this is a very cool experiment and each
of those 96 pressure ports can be
independently actuated at very high or
low frequencies to pulse air to try to
to manipulate and perturb this flow to
give it either more or less mixing okay
and so throughout this experimental
campaign Vladimir and Behrendt and
collaborators essentially tried to
design control laws to optimize this
high level objective function and it
turned out that Genetic Programming
control was the most effective strategy
that we tried so again you had this kind
of control scheme where your actuation
what those pressure ports do is some
complicated nonlinear function of what
you're measuring downstream and feeding
that back and learning that control
structure with the Genetic Programming
gives you the ability for vastly
improved control performance and so I'm
just going to walk you through what that
looks like in this case so here what we
have is called a pseudo visualization so
time goes from left to right and what
each vertical strip is showing are these
24 Hotwire measurements so kind of you
know dark or light would be you know big
positive or big negative flow velocities
and so you can kind of see the pseudo
visualization and those 24 hot wire
measurements
in time evolving okay so you can see
these kind of big vortex roll-up events
happening it looks really cool the top
plot here is the natural flow unforced
so this is a flow with no forcing it's
just evolving at this downstream
location and what you see in the middle
is open-loop forcing so basically you
take these pressure ports and you just
pulse them at some periodic frequency
that's why you see like dark light dark
light dark light and this periodic
frequency and it essentially just pulses
them on and off to try to increase or
decrease mixing downstream I think in
this case we were trying to increase
mixing and you can see that these
structures are much broader much bigger
so you get more mixing kind of this
broader wake downstream at the hot wire
with this open loop control strategy in
the bottom you see this Genetic
Programming control so this
machine-learning control is in the
bottom here and what it was able to do
is get similar mixing performance so the
the amount of mixing downstream is
similar to this middle open-loop plot
meaning that the wake had a bigger width
and you had more mixing downstream but
notice that it was able to do it with
much less control expenditure so white
means your control is on and you can get
similar mixing maybe even a little bit
better mixing but you can do it with
very very much much less control signal
so there's a lot less of this kind of
region where the control is on these
white regions and it's also not periodic
so it is a function of what the flow
state is instantaneously it gets fed
back and it allows you to use this
sensor control to get much more
efficient mixing increase okay so I hope
that made sense basically the the top is
the natural flow the middle is open-loop
forcing at a periodic frequency kind of
the best periodic frequency this was
optimized and the bottom is the Genetic
Programming control which obtains
similar mixing enhancement but with much
much decreased actuation cost you have
to blow out of these ports much less of
the time okay so that is kind of the
basic idea and after this experiment
Burt Nowak and collaborators have
applied this to
tons of flow experiments all across
Europe from drag reduction behind a car
- you know changing the recirculation
zone behind a ramp all kinds of examples
I think boundary layers you name it
very flexible architecture and it's
particularly well-suited to experiments
where you can get data very quickly to
assess was this a good control law or a
bad control law I don't know exactly how
long this time range is but I think this
was something like two seconds so within
a very short amount of time you can tell
was this a good control law or a bad
control law you can try hundreds of
individuals in a generation
dozens of generations in the matter of a
day so you can get the data you need to
do this machine learning optimization
this genetic programming control in a
matter of hours if you if you have a
fast experiment okay so that's kind of
an overview of how genetic programming
control has been used for turbulence
control very important application
incredibly hard problem that's occupied
many many many experts in the field for
four decades and there's some hope now
this is only one strategy of using
machine learning to optimize a control
lot to manipulate this system but
there's this increasing opportunity with
better data methods better optimization
techniques faster computers to really
start doing this this optimization on on
really important problems at scale and
I'll also point out that improved
sensors and actuators are also key so
having the ability to perturb your flow
and in you know exploit flow
sensitivities with actuation and having
better sensors to measure what your flow
is doing are also driving driving
progress in this field ok thank you